(Rires)
Il est facile de penser ainsi,
surtout quand on voit quelques exemples importants
qui dominent la conversation.
Il s’avère qu'à long terme, il n'y arrivent pas.
Morgan McCall et Michael Lombardo ont me né d'excellentes recherches
quand ils étaient au Centre pour la Direction créative.
Ils ont découvert que la principale raison liée à l'échec de l'exécutif
était un style insensible, abrasif ou intimidant.
Il y aura toujours des exceptions qui réussissent malgré leur incivilité
Tôt ou tard, cependant,
la plupart des gens incivils sabotent leur réussite.
Par exemple, avec les cadres incivils,
ça se retourne contre eux quand ils sont en position de faiblesse
ou qu'ils ont besoin de quelque chose.
Les gens ne les soutiendront pas.
Et pour les personnes gentilles ?
La civilité paie-t-elle ?
Oui.
Et être civil ne signifie pas seulement que tu n'es pas une enflure.
Ne pas rabaisser quelqu'un, ce n'est pas l'encourager.
Être réellement civil signifie faire les petites choses,
comme sourire et dire bonjour dans les couloirs,
écouter attentivement quand quelqu'un vous parle.
Mais, vous pouvez avoir des opinions tranchées,
être en désaccord, avoir un conflit ou donner votre avis négatif civilement,
avec respect.
Certains appellent ça la « candeur radicale » :
on est concerné personnellement,
mais on défie de façon directe.
Donc oui, la civilité paie.
Dans une entreprise de biotechnologie, nous avons decouvert
que ceux qui étaient percus comme civils
étaient deux fois plus susceptibles d’être vus comme chefs,
et travaillaient beaucoup mieux.
Pourquoi la civilité paie-t-elle ?
Parce que les gens vous voient comme une importante - et puissante -
combinaison unique de deux principales caractéristiques :
cordialité et compétence, sympathie et intelligence.
En d'autre termes, être civil ne se limite pas à motiver les autres.
C'est aussi ce que vous êtes.
Si vous êtes civil, vous serez plus volontiers perçu comme un chef.
Vous travaillerez mieux, et on vous verra comme amical et compétent.
Mais la façon dont la civilité paie va bien plus loin.
C'est lié à l'une des questions les plus importantes au sujet de la leadership :
qu'est-ce que les gens attendent le plus de leurs chefs ?
On a récolté les données de plus de 20 000 employés dans le monde entier,
et on a trouvé une réponse simple :
du respect.
Être traité avec respect est plus important
que la reconnaissance et l'appréciation,
les retours utiles,
et même les possibilités d'apprentissage.
Ceux qui se sentent respectés sont en meilleure santé,
plus concentrés,
plus susceptibles de rester dans leur organisation
et bien plus impliqués.
Alors, par où commencer ?
Comment encourager les gens et les faire se sentir respectés ?
L'avantage, c'est que ça ne nécessite pas de grand changement.
De petites choses peuvent faire une grande différence.
J'ai découvert que remercier les gens,
partager le mérite,
écouter attentivement,
poser humblement des questions,
reconnaître les autres, et sourire,
a un impact.
Patrick Quinlan, l'ancien directeur général de Ochsner Health [System],
m'a parlé des effets de leur méthode du 10-5 :
quand on est à trois mètres de quelqu'un,
on établit un contact visuel et on sourit,
et à un mètre cinquante,
on dit bonjour.
Il a expliqué que la civilité se répand,
les scores de satisfaction des patients augmentent,
ainsi que leurs recommandations.
La civilité et le respect peuvent servir
à augmenter la performance d'une entreprise.
Quand mon ami Doug Conant a pris le poste de PDG de Campbell's Soup Company en 2001,
la part de marché de l'entreprise avait chuté de moitié.
Les ventes diminuaient,
beaucoup de gens avaient été licenciés.
Un directeur de Gallup a dit que c'était l'entreprise la moins impliquée
qu'ils avaient sondé.
Quand Doug est allé au travail le premier jour,
il a remarqué que le quartier général étaient entouré d'une clôture de barbelés.
Il y avait des tours de garde dans le parking.
Il a dit que ça ressemblait à une prison fédérale.
Que ça semblait néfaste.
En cinq ans, Doug a changé les choses.
Et en neuf ans, ils ont enregistré des records sans précédent
et accumulé des prix, y compris le meilleur endroit où travailler,
Comment a-t-il fait ?
Le premier jour, Doug a dit aux employés
qu'il allait avoir des normes de performance élevées,
mais qu'ils allaient le faire avec civilité.
Il a joint le geste à la parole, et il a attendu ça de ses chefs aussi.
Pour Doug, il s'agit d'être dur avec les normes
et gentil avec les gens.
Pour lui, il a dit qu'il s'agissait de tous ces points de contact,
ou ces interactions quotidiennes qu'il avait avec les employés,
que ce soit dans les couloirs, à la cafétéria ou dans les réunions.
Et que s'il gérait correctement chaque point de contact,
il valoriserait les employés.
Une autre façon pour Doug de valoriser les employés
et leur montrer qu'il faisait attention,
est qu'il a écrit à la main plus de 30 000 cartes de remerciement aux employés.
Et ça a servi d'exemple aux autres chefs.
Les chefs ont environ 400 de ces points de contact par jour.
La plupart ne prennent pas trop de temps, moins de deux minutes chacun.
L'important, c'est d'être souple et conscient dans chacun de ces moments.
La civilité encourage les gens.
On pousse les gens à donner plus et donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes
si on est civil.
L'incivilité affaiblit les gens et leur performance.
Elle les prive de leur potentiel,
même s'ils la contournent.
Ce que ma recherche m'a appris est que quand on a des environnements plus civils,
on est plus productifs, créatifs, utiles, heureux et en bonne santé.
On peut faire mieux.
Chacun d'entre nous peut être plus conscient
et prendre des mesures pour encourager les autres autour de nous,
au travail, à la maison, en ligne,
dans les écoles
et dans nos communautés.
Dans chaque interaction, il faut se dire :
qui veux-tu être ?
Mettons fin au virus de l'incivilité
et commençons à répandre la civilité.
Après tout, ça paie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)